a 21 year old man who was stabbed to
death at the notting hill carnival has
been named today by his manager as
rapper takayo nambard the rapper from
bristol who went by the stage name
t-core stretch had been at the carnival
with his younger sister a warning that
the images we're about to show you were
taken in the moments after the rapper
was stabbed
while several officers tried to revive
him however he later died in hospital a
murder investigation is now underway and
police are appealing to festival goers
to come forward with any information
they may have a number of violent
incidents broke out at the end of this
year's carnival including several
serious stabbings marring the end of a
festival which was attended by more than
a million people
there were hundreds of people in the
immediate vicinity when this incident
took place
i would urge anyone who saw anything who
has video footage or who has any other
information that could assist officers
to come forward
tonight our thoughts are with the family
of the young man who has lost his life
in this senseless attack
uh joining us now from west london is
our crime correspondent martin brunt
who's following developments for us
martin talk to us about what's happening
in the police investigation at the
moment
as the hunt for the killer or killers
goes on no word from the metropolitan
police of an arrest and continuing
appeal for information uh the
metropolitan police have given more
details of um an escalation of violence
uh last night the second
day of the carnival and towards the
closing hours last night they told us
that there were apart from the fatal
stabbing six other stabbings in which
people were injured
this was on monday night
the second day
of the carnival and in previous
carnivals where there has been trouble
it's tended to come as darkness falls
towards the end of that that second day
they've also told us the met police that
there were 74 of their officers who were
injured
no real breakdown of the injuries but
some of those were the results say
the met police of assaults on those
officers and they've also
told us that there were 441
searches of people at the carnival now
as that
violence escalated on the second evening
police introduced special measures
section 60 which gave them the powers to
stop people at will without any specific
suspicion about those individuals so
over the two days there were 441
people who were stopped and searched
the other figures that the police gave
us earlier in the day remain the same
209 people were arrested
46 of them for assaults 36 for drugs
possession and 33 for the possession
of offensive weapons and uh there were
other
more minor um offences for which people
were arrested but so far
no word of any arrests in the major
thrust of this investigation for the
killer or killers